So guys, we're going to be doing strategic follow up in between all these leads.
We're not just going to send them five leads and get on the call and hope they've gotten
a hold of them.
So here's a couple of rules of thumb that I'm going to teach you that I do.
Number one, I do not send and you are not going to send the second lead until they have
scheduled an estimate with the first or the first has told them to go screw themselves
because something happened along the way.
Until the first is taken care of, meaning they have scheduled an estimate, they're not
getting number two and they're not getting number three until number two is taken care
of because what I've seen happen too often, and I used to do this, you go and you start
pumping them three, four, five leads and guess what?
They haven't even gotten a hold of the first one.
You want to prove through your actions, not just through your words, that these leads
are digital freaking gold.
So don't send number two until number one has been taken care of.
So what I'll typically do is let's say that we try to do the first live transfer, it doesn't
answer.
We do a three way text and I have another lead to send.
I will call the business owner and I will say, hey, sorry to bug you.
I'm not going to be annoying.
And that's the other thing I want to talk about.
Don't be annoying.
I want you to be at the top and forefront of their mind, but you are there to help them
not be annoying.
You need to be persistent, but you don't need to be overbearing.
So you're going to call them and say, hey, I have another lead that's come in.
I want to make sure you got a hold of Janet first.
Did she get scheduled?
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Not yet.
Okay.
Well, why don't you get her scheduled and I'll get this other lead ready to go.
And as soon as it's scheduled, I'll send it over.
Okay, guys, you need to be doing this.
You need to prove to them through your actions that these are digital gold.
And until you start treating them this way, the business owner is not going to take them
seriously.
Do not send five leads, show up on the Zoom call and then be surprised they got a hold
of none of them.
Do not send lead number two until lead number one has been scheduled for an estimate.
Okay.
So that's number one.
Number two, as I said, do not be annoying, be persistent, be top of mind, but don't be
annoying.
You're there to help them.
And if they have, if they're, if in the, the, this process in the live transfer process,
they can't stand you.
They're not going to want to work with you, but you need to be persistent.
You need to let them know through your actions that these leads mean everything to you.
This partnership means everything to you.
And these soft touches in between each lead is an opportunity for you to get comfortable
with the business owner, get that relationship with the business owner.
Last point I want to cover, guys, is what's going to happen occasionally is you're going
to send that first lead, okay.
And all of a sudden you're going to get ghosted or you think you're getting ghosted, okay.
You sent the first lead and you just can't get a hold of them.
And they're just not responding.
They're not answering your calls.
They're not answering your texts.
And you're like, what do I do?
Do I send the second lead?
Do I go find somebody else?
What do I do?
I'm going to tell you what to do.
You are going to use a pullback, okay.
And if you don't know what that is, you didn't watch the previous module and I want you to
go watch it, okay.
And if you want to refresh, go watch the module before and there's a video called the pullback.
This is a perfect opportunity to use a pullback.
And you're going to do something that I know it goes against the grain.
I know it probably frightens you, but you are going to gain control of the situation
because you are the one giving them leads.
You are the one that has what they need and they're the ones that are basically through
their actions telling you, hey bro, hey lady, you know, we're doing this on my time, okay.
So you need to get control of that situation and you don't need to get too aggressive,
but you need to be firm.
So quick example, let's say I've sent one or two leads.
These are good leads.
I listened to them and now they're not answering, okay.
I'm trying to get a hold of them to make sure they've scheduled number two and they're not
answering.
I've called them twice.
I've text them twice.
I'm going to do a pullback in the form of basically what I would, I would call this
a breakup tech.
So we're going to get into that later, but essentially I'm going to call them, leave
a voicemail or I'm going to text them and say something like this, Hey Jim, Nick here.
I, Hey, I've tried to get ahold of you for the past 24 hours.
I have two or three more leads that are piling up and I can't get ahold of you.
Look, if you're not interested and you're too busy to handle these leads and I'm just
making your problems worse, no problem.
But I need to know, I need to hear from you within X timeframe or I've got to move on
to the next company.
Thanks Nick.
Okay.
Something simple to the point, but something that slaps, something that freaking punches
them in the face.
It says, Hey lady, Hey guy, you need to answer these, my damn calls.
You need to answer my texts because I'm the one that's freaking putting money in your
mouth, putting money in your pocket, spoon feeding you leads in your mouth or I'm moving
on.
Okay.
So this is an opportunity to use a pullback.
So guys, just to reiterate, do not be afraid to use pullbacks.
This is a perfect chance to use a pullback.
And if you get ghosted at any point during the process of sending these live transfer
leads, do the pullback, get control of the situation back and get back onto the sales
process.